dans un certain nombre d'articles on
découvre les coulisses et la préparation
de l'équipe de joe biden pour cet
échange le président américain qui se
déplacent entouré de nombreux
conseillers ainsi que le secrétaire
d'état anthony blinken
c'est avec ces équipes qu'ils préparent
minutieusement son entretien avec
vladimir poutine faisant même en sorte
de ne rien prévoir à son agenda les
matinées de son déplacement en europe
pour se concentrer sur cet événement sa
femme dit de lui qu'il est sûr préparé
bayonne a d'ailleurs profité de ses
échanges avec les dirigeants européens
et de l'otan pour leur faire part de ses
intentions lors de sa rencontre avec
poutine ainsi que pour récolter leurs
idées leurs positions l'idée on l'a bien
compris pour je baille données d'arrivée
avec l'image d'un président soutenu par
ses alliés un président prêt à aborder
les sujets qui fâchent mais toute cette
préparation n'a pas empêché un premier
couac c'est andy dans un premier temps
ouvert à l'idée d'un échange de
cybercriminels avec la russie dans le
cadre d'un procédé d'extradition by
donne ensuite été corrigé par la maison
blanche qui est revenu sur cette idée
pour modérer la teneur expliquant que la
phrase du président américain avait été
surinterprétée concernant la forme les
médias américains explique que joe biden
espère parler franchement et sans détour
au président russe
ce ne sera pas la première rencontre
entre les deux hommes puisqu'il s'était
entretenue en 2011 lorsque byden était
alors vice président des états unis
beaucoup souligné si la volonté de baden
de marquer une forme de rupture avec la
diplomatie de donald trump et c'est
d'ailleurs pour cela qu'il a décidé de
ne pas participer à une conférence de
presse conjointe avec le président russe
il faut dire que trump avait été
critiqué très vivement après cet
exercice lors de sa rencontre avec
poutine s'était helsinki en 2018
malgré ces précautions joe biden est lui
aussi critiqué car si la plupart des
médias se montre clément certains
observateurs ou élus politiques
redoutent que le président américain ne
se montre pas suffisamment offensif avec
son homologue russe
c'est le cas par exemple du sénateur
républicain ted cruz qui qualifie
d'erreur géopolitique la fin des
sanctions américaines contre le projet
north stream de bayonne sera le
cinquième président américain en
exercice à rencontrer vladimir poutine
des discussions qui se sont avérés
compliqués dans le passé pour certains
de ses prédécesseurs et qui constitue un
pro
les gros test pour le nouveau président
américain